so i sort of mentioned in passing in my
story about martial law
earlier in the show that the mayor of
portland was tear gassed along with
protesters recently by donald trump's
federal troops
operating under the banner of homeland
security but i never really gave you the
details of what
happened there so not only was portland
mayor ted wheeler gassed
president donald trump seemed to brag
about it
here's donald trump during an outrageous
fox news interview first of all notice
trump doesn't even know the guy's name
his name is ted wheeler
trump calls him waylon and then sean
hannity corrects him
and then trump brags about wheeler
getting
the hell knocked out of him and it's not
to be totally honest it's not clear if
trump's referring to getting tear gassed
or that he was booed
but take a look at the clip and then
we'll discuss and
they were going wild for 51 days and we
went in and
they've done a great job they're going
to rip down the courthouse a big federal
courthouse gorgeous federal courthouse
so we went in and we've been very very
strong and we have this
mayor whalen who i think is also he's
also
the police commissioner as i understand
it
yeah mayor wheeler and he's uh
he made a fool out of himself liz he
wanted to be among the people so he went
into the crowd and they knocked the hell
out of him
that was the end of him so it was pretty
uh pretty pathetic
but we want to go in and help the cities
we want to help chicago so indeed a few
days ago
ted wheeler was hit with tear gas while
he was standing with protesters near the
courthouse and
just about everything trump says
in that very short clip is false uh
trump calls
the mayor whelan hannity corrects him so
he gets the guy's name wrong
trump says that protesters were going
wild for 51 days that's
certainly not true again unless donald
trump is actually
you know some kind of uh physicist that
has a different conception of what time
means by no measure have the protesters
been going wild for 51 days
trump says the courthouse was going to
be ripped down
that's not true but the really shocking
thing here
is that it is so dictatorial
and so authoritarian that trump is
ridiculing ted wheeler
for being on the side of the public
against the federal paramilitaries
in other words overwhelmingly people
don't want these federal troops in
portland
now i've gotten a couple emails over the
weekend
from people saying you know david you
should see that there are
like individuals someone told me
although i haven't confirmed that brett
weinstein
wants the troops there uh because he
says
you know the rest of the country doesn't
really understand what's going on i
don't i
i don't know if that's true i got a few
emails about that overwhelmingly
people don't want these troops there the
mayor doesn't want the troops there
and the local law enforcement
authorities are not working
in conjunction with these troops in
anything that would be called
a cooperative way and the mayor as a
citizen is joining the people
that's great now yeah the mayor was
booed by some people when he did this
and that relates to
you know people may be displeased with
the mayor's handling of the situation
but shouldn't we like it when elected
officials instead of hanging out in the
safety of their ivory towers if portland
has
ivory towers i don't know and making
declarations
wouldn't it be better if people uh
were joined by elected officials
isn't that what we want to see now i
know that there will be situations where
it doesn't feel genuine
and when mitt romney a republican
senator
joined the black lives matter protests
wearing a mask no less in washington dc
joining mostly left wingers let's be
honest about it
uh and he was asked what are you doing
here senator he said i'm here because
black lives matter and he
kept his mask on and he did it there
were people who said this is
disingenuous romney this is the guy who
was going to lower taxes on millionaires
oh yeah that's true it's it's romney it
is that guy he's still a republican
but i think it's important when a
republican says hey
i have to choose the movement over my
party in this particular case
i think that it should be applauded but
with some healthy skepticism that these
are still politicians who are
calculating what they do
the point is we should be glad
when elected officials join movements
rather than just
sending out messages on twitter or
hanging out in their office
and donald trump is ridiculing ted
wheeler for hearing the voice of the
people and joining them in their
peaceful protests
this isn't getting that much attention
but it is insanely authoritarian the
president sits in dc
and essentially laughs at a public
servant who is joining people
and says he got the hell knocked out of
him again it's not was that from
he was tear gas but it's not clear if
trump was referring to that
so we have to recognize this for what it
is and to follow up on the earlier story
about martial law and authoritarianism
federal troops are being sent around to
different cities a growing list of
cities
to satisfy donald trump's whims and
to as trump sees it generate chaos
that will help get him reelected we just
can't allow it to work but this is his
plan
now to get ahead of a narrative that's
being floated already
if you look in some reactionary and
right-wing circles
there you might be shocked by this there
are some right-wingers abandoning their
so-called
small government values and saying i
support the paramilitaries because these
protesters deserve it
because they are criminals again the
protesters
aren't criminals they are protesters
they are constitutionally protected
it is speech they are peaceably
assembling
and they are asking for the redress of
of grievances that they are bringing
forward
if they are criminals then they are
criminals
right protesters aren't criminals
protesters are the patriots here and
that's the something the right doesn't
want to accept
the right has attempted to hold the
monopoly on patriotism in the united
states for a long time
certainly i was most exposed to it
around the 2003 iraq war
but it's not new it's been going on for
decades and decades
the protesters are being patriotic
they are doing the things that our
country was enshrined upon
a protester is not a criminal now i've
said before
and i'll repeat it some of you disagree
breaking windows at a courthouse is not
going to forward any cause and it is a
crime
and you're going to be suffering the
consequences of committing a crime if
you do it
setting fires to buildings is not going
to further any cause
and it's a crime and you should expect
that if you do that
you are going to be arrested and charged
and it could be really bad
for you martin luther king was very
clear about this mark there's some
very interesting contrast look up videos
of interviews with martin luther king
and separately with malcolm x both of
whom
were bringing a lot of different ideas
forward
valuable ideas martin luther king
differed from malcolm x
and that martin luther king recognized
that when you
start using more violent tactics
arson destruction of property etc even
if you can morally defend it even if we
can all say an insurance company will
pay to rebuild the building who cares
okay
that's aside from the fact that people
could get hurt or killed uh
as bystanders martin luther king pointed
out
it often comes back to hurt exactly the
people
doing the protesting and when you
consider that many of these protests
are overwhelmingly white do we really
improve the situation for the people
that we are most trying to help
by introducing elements of violence here
which may only lead to even rougher
treatment by police of the very people
we are trying to help so
i do see that as self-destructive right
this is not a show where if you're
tuning in for me
to defend criminality that's not this
show
but most of the people are just
protesters it's moms now who have showed
up
to back up the protesters and then
veterans showed up
to back up the moms who are backing up
the protesters so
we can't let them set the narrative of
the troops or fine
because it's really mostly criminals
there and the protesters are criminals
no we can't let them set that narrative
and not letting them set the narrative
is just
part of part of what we need to be doing
for the next three months
one of our sponsors is cuts clothing and
they're giving you
15 off of everything they offer
when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's
c-u-t-s cuts clothing has
completely changed the game when it
comes to
solid color t-shirts obviously solid
color t-shirts
are an important staple in any wardrobe
which is all the more reason that you
should be wearing t-shirts that you
actually love
it really does impact your day-to-day
you've got your typical poorly made
t-shirt it's scratchy
it shrinks the neck becomes all floppy
the color fades it all starts to warp
over time
none of that happens with cuts clothing
as soon as i first put on a t-shirt from
cut's clothing
i could immediately tell the difference
between this
and the other poorly made shirts that
i've owned in the past and it's really a
very noticeable level of quality and
comfort and style
which i believe will change how you
think about t-shirts
go check out what they offer they also
have this new line of polo shirts
it's really more comfortable than any
polo shirt i've ever worn
cuts clothing will be a total game
changer when it comes to
t-shirts they're really the only t-shirt
worth buying
and now they've got the polos and you'll
get 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com cuts